Colonel Daniel Davis Senior fellow for
the defense priorities and Nathan sales
former Ambassador at large and
counterterror coordinator under
President Trump um let's start with you
Colonel Davis um again Peter's right you
know Americans they hear ho'sies I mean
they know it's trouble they probably
don't know much about this um
yemen-based group that's been launching
a Civil War uh against the uh yemeni
government now for many many years uh
what's your take on what you're hearing
so far tonight I tell you Laura I I'm
really concerned on a number of fronts
number one I want to know what's the
what's the plan here what is the
expectation what is the instate where
are we trying to go with this because if
we think that firing a few missiles is
going to cow the houthis and they're
going to stop doing what they're going
to do and they're going to be deterred I
mean that should be eliminated after
we've been seeing the failure of all
these strikes to eliminate to deter the
ironback groups against our troops in
Iraq and in Syria and elsewhere and
we've already taken out their boats
that's not going to to do it this has
every chance to escalate to a higher
level because the houth have expressly
said if we attack them on their
territory they're going to start
attacking Americans and American
interest in the region what is our plan
for that and and look this is a
potential strike that could draw us into
a war and I think the president owes it
to the American people to explain what
he's doing to make sure we want to go
into a war I don't but I'd like to hear
from the White House on exactly what the
plan is and how this follows American
law and the Constitution which it
doesn't
yeah well again calling a lid while
we're launching military strikes with uh
the UK in the Middle East seems to me
like mind-bogglingly outrageous but
Nathan uh Peter just mentioned this but
among the first U moves that Biden made
back in February uh 2021 right after he
was inaugurated was to officially lift
the designation of the U Iranian boutis
uh in Yemen as a global Terror
organization now how idiotic does that
look
tonight yeah Laura it's a real heads
scratcher during the Trump
Administration we were willing to call a
spade a spade and so we said you know
the houthis are launching terrorist
attacks against oil infrastructure
against our allies against ships if it
looks like a terrorist it's a terrorist
and so we put them on the list the Biden
folks and and let me tell you we got
crucified in the media for doing that we
were called baby killers because people
said this is going to prevent the
delivery of humanitarian assistance well
things look a lot different today um and
it's kind of ironic Laura that you know
the the president is now engaged in
combat against a group that he removed
from the terrorist list so that's a bit
of a puzzle to think through I mean but
when you think about this again the head
of the hooti um group came out in a
video just hours ago saying you strike
us and we're coming after you we also
Colonel Davis have an open border right
now we know terrorists have exploited
the Border we've caught some of
them who knows who's in this country now
another reason why we need a total
change in leadership we're going to get
into this with Molly um and cianne in a
moment but this is a dangerous situation
we're setting up well it is and
unfortunately this thing is long in the
building so there's no easy answers here
there's no obvious Solutions but I do
share your concerns about the fact that
there has been you can't even call it a
porest border it's just been wide open
and God only knows who all's coming in
and there could be you know sleeper
agents in there right now I I don't have
any knowledge whether there are but
there is a very real possibility that
that is somebody wants to harm our
country could already be here Nathan is
it a point of interest that Germany and
France did not choose to join this
effort tonight obviously the two larger
economies in the EU you is let the UK
and the US handle
this yeah you know I I'm not sure that
if other countries from Europe were to
participate that that would actually be
a good thing because it tends to be the
lowest common denominator response um
the US and the UK we've got some reps we
know how to take terrorists off the
battlefield um and so you know I'm
pretty comfortable with the Eisenhower
and its British counterpart leading this
now what concerns me Laura we've been
telegraphing all day the fact that these
strikes were coming if there is ay
terrorist in Yemen for hours if there is
a houy terrorist who was surprised by
this like they've got to be the dumbest
terrorist in the world it would surprise
me if we actually manag to eliminate any
of their leaders or the people who are
responsible for these attacks on
Americans and on commercial shipping it
looks like the administration was
telegraphing this strike precisely to
avoid casualties on the part of the
hoies now we want a successful Mission
here but but to that point Colonel Davis
it does remind me a little bit of what
happened with our withdrawal from
Afghanistan I mean we had our our
service Personnel standing out there
they were sitting ducks and we lost
precious American lives because of that
now we don't think that kind of thing is
going to happen but again telling the
enemy what we're doing where we are
where we're standing when we're coming I
mean they told us I think within about
15 minutes that we knew it was coming
yeah that's one of my enduring concerns
out here is that we have all those
troops that are just sitting out in the
middle of the desert in Iraq and Syria
with they they the enemy has you know
detailed coordinates of exactly where
they are and it's not that hard to shoot
them and add to it if they want to but
you know what the other thing that I
haven't heard well we haven't heard
anything from the White House but I I
dang sure want to hear quickly what next
because what happens if if the huies
make good on this threat and they do hit
some of our interests they do hit some
of our people somewhere else they do
strike somewhere in the border now what
are you going to do because now we have
to escalate up even higher now we're
taking what is a problem in the Red Sea
and it could be drawing us into a war
which God only knows where that could go
and they we do not need a new war now
and Nathan right on Q giv my last
question to you Politico just reported
that the US and the UK did have support
from Australia the Netherlands Bahrain
and Canada in these strikes but again no
France and Germany we um we don't know
the extent of their support could be
intelligence support um we obviously
have the hardware and we should have the
Intel support but maybe we should stop
spying on Americans and focus more on on
the real threats um but does that
Coalition give you some comfort
Nathan I think so the these are
countries that have a lot of skin in the
game our fifth Fleet is based in Bahrain
um in the region so they're obviously
going to be a key player um Australia
and the other countries you mentioned
like these are some of our closest
allies
um they have excellent intelligence
collection capabilities but really what
they add above all um is is is the
support of diplomatic heft it's it's
good to know that you've got allies in
your corner who are prepared uh to
support you even if that just means
moral support though of course the more
uh assets the more intelligence
information they can share and devote to
this Mission the better well again this
also reminds us Colonel Davis
of why it's so important that we knew
where our defense secretary was and that
the White House was in close
coordination with him I mean I go back
to what I said you know a few days ago
the real story there was that apparently
he was so insignificant to daily
briefings they weren't even looking for
him I mean I worked in the Reagan
Administration I'm really dating myself
but C Weinberger if he was missing for
15 minutes they know about it they
didn't know about this for four days
what message does that send our
adversaries not a good one yeah and I
think it's it's even worse than that
because look this is exactly what I on
our deep dive show a couple of days ago
this is what I talked about if something
unexpected happens and the president
needs to talk to the secf right now he's
at he's awall he's not even there so you
can't even reach him it's unconscionable
that he would have not told the
president or his Deputy where he was for
two days and this is exactly the reason
why all right Gentlemen please stay with
us hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else